I had a chief of staff who I was lucky
to work with for a year named Kimberly
Cotton and she was the chief of staff to
the CEO of this Fortune 500 company. I
met her backstage speaking at a a large
event for that company. Turns out her
CEO was retiring. Anyway, to make a long
story short, she was a master question
asker and she illuminated for me
something that I had experienced over my
life, which is there are three types of
questions
that you can ask someone that really
actually make a difference that help
shape or edit the future in some way.
And so, in this video, I'm going to give
you what I believe are three way better
conversation starters that maybe could
replace all ice breakers. And I'm going
to get really close and intense to share
these three framings. At one level, you
can ask possibility questions, right?
What is possible? Sharing a vision for
what is possible in the future. On the
next level, you ask process questions
like it's a little bit more digging into
like the how do you actually wind up
there? And then green Kim was amazing at
asking practical questions. So I would
share this vision or an idea for
something and she was a master of
saying, "Ah, that's amazing.
By when would you like to have that
done?" So let me give you three
questions that I really love that you
can walk someone through right from
possibility into process into a very
practical place. You ready? At the
possibility level of questions, you're
really talking about uh vision, right?
Getting someone's larger aim. It doesn't
need to be hyper specific. You're just
like, "What do you want?" Right? Those
kinds of questions. If I ask you a
question like, "What does this question
say? If you could solve one problem in
the world, what would it be?"
And so when I hear somebody's response
to that, right? What I now am getting
curious if I'm if I'm kind of hovering I
almost picture these uh possibility
process and practical like a spiral
where you you got to start in the land
of possibility in the land of like why
what's the point what's the big vision
otherwise and what happens too often is
when we try to get actionoriented
uh we ask practical questions. Practical
questions are great at generating a
bunch of activity that lead to nowhere
because they're not tied to some larger
vision. And so when you start with the
level of possibility and you spiral down
to like how's it going to get done
process
when I ask you a question like what
brings you joy and then I'm able to
combine that with okay you want to solve
this problem and what brings you uh joy
I can now start to think like how do
those intersect how might you combine
those so there's some reflection and
debriefing to be happening there and
then really practically what is it that
you want to start doing so you can see
this is just three question examples Um,
I got so on about this idea that
questions are the edit button to the
future. That uh questions that are
future focused. What they do is spark
the tiny actions,
which is us verbalizing, us creating new
neural pathways that lead to actual
implementation out in the world. And so
what I did is spent a whole heap of time
packing 60 possibility process and
practical questions into what I believe
is the coolest tool to replace all other
ice breakers or conversation starters.
Um and it is the future focused we
connect cards and it's really uh simply
a deck designed to help people talk
their way into a more compelling
interesting tomorrow. The no prep
takeaway here is that when you're in a
group, if you can start with possibility
questions as a conversation starter and
then take their answers to that and add
a processoriented question of like how
do you like going about that
and then drop it into really practically
like what's the tiniest action you might
want to take in the next week to make
that happen. That sequence of
possibility to process to practical is
transformative for a group. And so if
you want to start conversations that
actually go somewhere that make a
difference, that is your formula. If you
want to pick up a deck of these cards,
they're available on the internet. I
guess they're sponsoring this video. I
don't know. Have an awesome day.